[Music]
and all you need is love news all you
need is love money and food would help
to love it
I was submitted by Korean barbecue
Queens whoo you must have a lot of acne
can you a smell a tired police officer
talked down a knife wielding assailant
and then embraces him with a hug to stop
the chaos and then he stabs in mind the
back and kills him with both of them
together what we saw don't do it and he
stabs him in the back and all the way
through him and they died together
that's a super [ __ ] samurai sword
yeah I know what kind of daggers can you
do that with like the white people buck
knife Oh looks nicer like this big you
can't spend two people what have you
seen how skinny Thai people are the hell
is hitting about Charlie Chaplin
so this dude in Thailand is 45 year old
he went into a police station and he was
very upset you're saying that he's a
musician he had been working as a
security guard for three days and had
not been paid and so on top of all this
his guitar was stolen well cuz only been
three days bro your checks on incoming
three days maybe they paid daily okay
oddly you might have to wait like a few
more weeks yeah and then so like all
that was talking about and so I guess
that led to him doing this doing what
what do you do again so what he did is
he went to the police station with and
he was just like wielding a knife you
wonder you shot a video [ __ ] I'm dressed
pow there's no sound
okay somebody stole my guitar somebody
that that loves Ringo
yeah so this is the assailant like the
real dialogue second olanta kappa no no
no in your head a local anybody here
what are you doing man come on I do
though what do you do
hey bro come here man it's all right
thank America I having a bad back I just
can't watch out hey I'm just letting you
know Jessica have it love you made it oh
you've been a hard day man how can one
guy is so [ __ ] huge
everyone's usually screenings but it
looks kind of huge everyone's bidding
except for that guy that musician is not
very smart they are in a police station
you know that's that's actually kind of
like I mean I was joking about it before
it's still funny to me but it's also
kind of beautiful it is very beautiful
because sometimes people just need a
[ __ ] hug that's why I be hugging
people all the [ __ ] time
why did he go and though he was stressed
Allan Simonsen Sousa what I don't
understand is like there's no purpose
like I understand him going into the
bank I'm stressed out I need a million
dollars you're like I understand the the
7-eleven either did pay maybe he felt
like he had no support like you guys are
[ __ ] here and this shit's happening to
me worried why are you doing your
[ __ ] job almost 100% sure if I was
the cop and I came for a honky with a
stab the [ __ ] out of me
cuz like come on bro you know Papa let's
kind of make with your ego against so
much like bad bad media unlike cost then
again this is entire and stuff yeah Alan
America he was not blasted I thought he
was going to Moya kick him to the face
oh that tight cop was pretty big you're
a little too casual to he kind of just
sat on the table so girl from how he was
trying to be like as non-confrontational
as possible I think you heard it in a
dudes voice where he's like this he
doesn't really want to do any harm he
just stressed out the guy looked like a
very old man he did look kind of like
Frehley like he was holding the knife
like yeah I'm not sure a nice guy or the
police kind of nice guy he's 45 he looks
older than that yeah 45 it'd be nice if
more people kind of like treated
problems like that you know instead of
just like going straight into like
fighting and but actually talking it out
but sometimes though
and I have been in situations where even
on among friends where I try to break up
a fight and they're so angry to swing at
me
yeah will help reduce don't go [ __ ] it
if you start swinging everybody and
that's when the homies come in and have
to beat them up falls at the same time
yeah
and then you never know because there's
crazy people out there that are like oh
I just need help and I kill you them in
their death yeah
little of it this officer's name is a
new route and he was saying that he
heard him out he sympathized with this
assailant and she told them that he had
a guitar to give him oh he got all that
conversation in just that and Ty is fast
yes have you ever thought stupid off the
probic got a whole lot very that's
really fast not offered for them to go
and eat together as a friend did some
Thai boat noodles so then after all this
happened the 45 year old is taken to a
hospital to evaluate his mental state
but no charges were filed well that's
awesome yeah all these news they're just
they've been really nice we've actually
really really nice to hear that song I
like it can I tell you has a negative
story though no way to ruin a moment let
me tell terrible story really quick
that's a David does all the time because
how sad the elderly how a friend of a
friend died and how tragic that does I
wish I could say names but people don't
feel comfortable when you tell their
full name so anyways this is not but
this is our Jesse from simple to cup he
was in no hood all they know is that
ever happened to he'll get was telling
me because they live in Hollywood or the
offices in Hollywood but he was telling
me that a cop told him that there are so
many bad things that happened in LA that
it's amazing that did it to him he
thought this would get lows but he said
like just before I got there to their
office that there was a homeless guy
walking around with a knife and he was
stabbing the [ __ ] out of people
oh my god is doing drive-by stabbings he
drives like will bike well and he was
stabbing people and then like you know
cops had to take him down anyone dies
luckily the people that he stabbed and
died but yet the the dude that was
stabbing people had to be put down
they killing she's like a rabbit they
had to shoot him because he was stabbing
the [ __ ] out of people
yeah so there's situations like that
where I think like it's a little bit
kind of like I'm not sure of opening
your arms up to that man would be a
great idea yeah never been stabbed
hey man I could give you the time on a
[ __ ] guitar but I want to stab people
yeah Ellie it's kind of crazy I think
over there they could practice a little
bit more to love and it's awesome yeah
maybe you could read them you just know
yeah you've been around so many
criminals and all that stuff you're an
officer you kind of just feel it out of
you like this guy not kind of do [ __ ] I
don't think you would be a patient
officer inpatient all I want to do [ __ ]
I told you - good things happen like if
he came up crying stabbing I would bring
another officer deal with it
conversational this thing is going on
over there maybe the government I hear a
Quan take care of it uh-huh obvious Quan
can you up then it depends on how happy
jail made me at home oh I was really
happy there not be very nice but me and
Jo grant a big fight the price killers
maybe that's a good thing that you're
not out there yeah I would 100% would
have ignored it to that collect right in
here no the guys like screaming the
David like sitting next to me just like
you know he comes any screaming right
I'll just you know [ __ ] worse well
there was a guy in there I wasn't doing
anything right somehow became a cop
which is not gonna happen
but even if I want to do it wouldn't
happen I don't know I don't think I
should ever be a copy yeah that guy's
David right there they got in the back
looks like on this computer like
nothing's happening nothing there's a
guy with his arms crossed back back here
see that that's me we're just on the
Internet I'm checking emails yeah he's
over here oh my god smart - oh you
would've gone nice first and then he
hugged them yeah so that he could shank
him yeah he look like he's got the right
in the back dog eyes but the hug is more
like let me just hold them in place till
backup and home but watch their signals
he totally got to go away he was no go
ahead that's really cool
I'm so awesome do we need more cops like
that we need more cops the guy in the
back who didn't do [ __ ]
let's speak up that's me actually I
thought maybe you're just registering
and like what's going on they are dad
yeah then they cut it could have made it
worse - at the same time because like
what situations like that if people just
kind of randomly jump in you could just
escalate actually that's what I'm saying
since maybe David has the right mindset
yep want to de-escalate the situation no
he's not deescalate and [ __ ] he's just
not doing anything about the escalating
yep so like let's say if I'm yelling at
David right if he yells back we're both
going to get even louder
but if he's just that one bit icky I'm
going to keep yelling and I'm eventually
get tired huh [ __ ] [ __ ] are
[ __ ] any wife but you get angry at me
right now and you yell I mean I'm
shooting a hollow handle has a cop
go what the [ __ ] you gotta listen to me
that so many [ __ ] problem got tired
you got tired I do something at him it
could have been a knife yeah he would
have been dead he wasn't dead no he has
to the plexiglas be no I mean I guess
it's kind of too good I mean you is it
when a kid throws a tantrum sometimes
they're just throwing a tantrum just
throw a tantrum and doing nothing can be
a means of de-escalating it right there
he understands me very well and look now
you're calm don't touch me
I don't do anything I'm a bystander I
think as soon as I see a guy with a
knife I start shooting him to me I think
there's a kind of there's a kind of cop
I'm going to get I'm the kind of table
that's going to be like sir can you
please hold this your weapon he had
something on air you with your body can
say weapon hundred name engraved on your
[ __ ] funny thing is that should
actually what I know what the [ __ ] you
were doing oh sure oh no and then your
body can just doesn't worry it's pile
and
it's Thailand you just show up like this
there hold this oh my god yeah a lesson
Oh she'll have even up to the car I pull
over and I'm gonna like excuse me ma'am
license and registration
can you hold this please and I'm his
partner in the car in the bag away she's
all like is the shift over yeah
do we have some ice cream a my shitty
cup or am I just a bystander shitty car
I can't really place judgment on me I'm
not doing anything that's why that's not
your job you does not to not do anything
my job is to uphold peace the best way I
know how and it's very peaceful to not
get involved exactly that's the most
peaceful thing to do exactly what I'm
forcing a line on that oh well but it's
like this right somebody's robbing a
home okay they'll break into the house
if they're running outside and no in my
vicinity I'll stop them however if they
broke it in right and I see the better
digital running they gotta go I'm gonna
catch them to make good today
I saw but I'm a witness and I saw that
happen I could write a really good
description yeah there's no point what
the whole point of them running me
running I sweat this came the results
the same don't get away they still don't
have a TV just I underpants in the
morning exactly we run the creases so
one situation is is they walk away with
the TV second such a way they still walk
away with TV but I'm dry now it's gonna
look like the Japanese police officer
Roenick extra slow the cameraman is
better than the both of them stop what
should be calm no hope you guys enjoyed
that video if you did a really cool way
to communicate that to us and for you to
never miss another video and by
subscribing
so click on that little subscribe button
and you'll never miss an episode for the
next episode click right up here
[Music]